lo que hasta hace pocas semanas era
material de combate hoy son obras de
exposición a las afueras del museo
nacional de historia militar de ucrania
en kiev se han expuesto los restos de
armamento del ejército ruso destruido
durante las semanas más duras de la
ofensiva rusa en la capital los
transeúntes caminan ahora porque es
entre pedazos de aviones y tanques de
combate se paran comentan e incluso se
toman fotos para algunos la exposición
de la destrucción del material de las
tropas del kremlin es un golpe a la
moral y les hace creer que la victoria
está más cerca para otros este material
debe permanecer expuesto para honrar la
historia
cuantos más vehículos enemigos
destruidos tengamos más cerca estará la
victoria
sentirnos moratones hay que recopilar
este material en lugares especiales para
crear museos lugares en los que se pueda
entrar y sumergirse en los recuerdos
esponja en la misma línea se expresa
pablo nt soft combatiente veterano
ucraniano quien manifestó que la
exposición del armamento ruso en la
capital es un acto para preservar la
historia
se trata de la preservación real de la
historia para que nadie puede decir no
ocurrió
el tiempo pasará y ya no habrá nada que
ver según el veterano de guerra es
importante que los civiles que
regresaron a kiev después de que la
ofensiva rusa se concentrará en el
donbass vean la magnitud de la guerra
frente a sus ojos
y a través de esta exhibición de
equipamiento militar quiero que la gente
entienda esta guerra como yo la veo como
está sucediendo en realidad watson los
prop
mientras las autoridades ucranianas
sostienen que el objetivo actual de
moscú pasa por hacerse con el control
total de las autoproclamadas repúblicas
de lugansk y donestsk en kiev los
vestigios de la ofensiva rusa conviven
con una extraña vuelta a la cotidianidad